il ya un sujet qui semble être réglé
c'est le cas de al bagdadi puisque le
président américain s'est félicité hier
de la mise hors d'état de nuire du chef
de dèche
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'il y
est allé de bon coeur écoutez le bourg
juste avant de faire réagir je vous fait
écouter la réaction du ministre des
affaires étrangères jean yves le drian
il était à abou dhabi mort vers l'adie
est un sérieux coup porté à déj
après la défaite de territoriale orma
ces derniers pourraient dire que cela
doit nous encourager à poursuivre nos
efforts pour éradiquer le terrorisme
salué l'action américaine à cet égard
salué aussi l'action de la coalition
contre d'âge qui n'a pas fini son
travail et la lutte contre le terrorisme
et la lutte en juillet contre douch est
un compact pour suivre ensemble et c'est
un sujet que nous aurons l'occasion au
sida board
alors en 2011 la mort de ben laden avait
permis à barack obama de grimper de 11
points dans les sondages de popularité
qui lui a permis de remonter 57%
d'opinions positives
jérôme sainte marie est-ce que vous
pensez que la cote de popularité de
donald trump va monter dans les mêmes
proportions je peux pas répondre pour ne
pas être démenti immédiatement dans tous
les sondages aux états y sont fait très
rapidement que ça se trouve on en a déjà
quand même compliqué parce que les faits
d'abord des attentats ou les faits au
compteur de victoires sur le front la
lutte anti terroriste ça c est fait là
sont très variables selon les moments et
donc c'est également sur mon épouse je
sais pas du tout il a quand même une
différence majeure entre les deux
personnages c'est que ben oussama ben
laden avait quand même hâte agresser les
américains sur leur territoire tandis
que
je me permets de rappeler quand même
parce que c'est un peu importants que
ceux qui ont agressé d'abord les gens
sur leur territoire c'est les américains
en 2003 qu ils envahissent l'irak
et quand ils détruisent les états parce
que cette question là là disponibles la
diplomatie française devrait avoir des
comptes à rendre également
ce qui apparaît quand même comme le
meilleur moyen de la lutte
antiterroriste c'est quand même de
maintenir des états digne de ce nom là
où ça existe
la destruction systématique des états
arabes notamment quand ils sont laïques
produit des effets invraisemblable et
ses effets là ils sont en ce qui nous
oblige à courir derrière je veux excuser
votre part un exemple particulier je
trouve que j'ai travaillé en afghanistan
demain il ya assez longtemps regardé la
guerre en afghanistan ça n'arrête pas de
dire vous avez alors là c'est un peu un
cas particulier ce que les têtes et déjà
défaits mais si vous prenez la et qu'au
contraire sur doute que la guerre en
irak est handicapé l'action de
l'international en afghanistan mais vous
prenez note l'action occidentale en
général dont celle de la france
d'ailleurs
même si on s'est opposé à la guerre en
irak au départ c'est quand même assez
calamiteux et là aussi on veut on voit
également tout ce qui est se passe en
syrie où effectivement on est en train
de manger notre chapeau en réalité trump
a ajouté on l'a pas mis dans l'extrait
que al bagdadi est mort comme un chien
comme un l'âge gémissant pleurant et
hurlant
dominique reynié ce que le président de
la mairie qu'un a raison d'utiliser ses
mots est-ce que ça risque pas d'avoir un
effet inverse c'est-à-dire de d'énergie
c'est plat de votre volonté vis-à-vis de
nouveaux déjà s'énerver comme ça
exactement ce qu'il faut c'est vrai
qu'il faut compter sur la bienveillance
mais non non c'est un cétacé bon c'est
que c'est son style sa façon de parler
qui est allé très très très franchement
moi je pense que c'est en pleine
harmonie avec son électorat son public
avec lequel il a une relation d'empathie
qu est très forte
incapable de vous dire s'il va être
réélu ou pas j'imagine connu tout ça
capable mais enfin mais par contre je
pense que là c'est par rapport à son
électorat son public
c'est une position très favorable après
jérôme sainte-marie le dit à l'instant
on sait pas bien c'est ces choses là
parce que ça peut être fort et pas
durable ça peut être décalé il ya plein
de
c'est pas bien on va mesurer des choses
et puis on verra si ça dure il reste
beaucoup d'inconnues je vais pas être
énorme et je voudrais juste dire que je
serais très surpris si l etat islamique
ne faisait pas de manière très rapide
la démonstration que bien sûr quelqu'un
remplace c'est déjà un peu ce qui se dit
on pas déjà un nom qui apparaît pour le
remplacer le chef disparu
et puis il faut espérer que ils perdront
davantage à faire la démonstration par
un attentat meurtrier ou une opération
spectaculaire et terrible de leur
capacité à toujours nourrir parce qu'à
ce moment là ce serait ce serait plus
compliqué juste points ça dépend aussi
donc du coût du contrôle de la région
par les russes les turcs et donc des
relations entre quand même les états
unis et la russie ça c'est rigolo de
voir que entre poutine et rome il ya
quand même là un truc qui peut guère la
qui peut bien les amener à discuter jour
si vous rejoins complètement ce qui est
dit coupez une tête de l'hydre ne fait
pas mourir la bête cette d'accord aussi
avec cette année je vais aller les
précédents l'ont montré même si c'est
effectivement une victoire stratégique
et une victoire militaire
la guerre n'est pas gagné pour tout le
monde le sait est évidemment l'état
islamique n'aura de cesse que de faire
la preuve de sa capacité de résilience
je sais pas sur quoi pour utiliser se
servent dans ce dans ce contexte
mais pour pour ce qui concerne la
politique intérieure américaine
il faut pas oublier que le lâchage des
kurdes
par donald trump avait été extrêmement
critique et à l'intérieur même du camp
conservateur et du camp week-end donc de
ce point de vue là ce coup d'éclat
qu'on pense à peu ce lâchage est brisée
fait ce lâchage
et c'est extrêmement important parce que
ce qui fait la force de donald trump
dans le coeur de son électorat c'est
l'économie pour l'instant ça va très
bien le chômage est à 3,7 à trucs comme
ça c'est à dire à son minimum
les perspectives ne sont pas bonnes et
pour y arriver il pourrait y avoir une
récession d'ici 18 mois ou deux ans au
quelqu'un l'a vraiment là la raison de
voter trump pourrait être ce sont le
seul affaibli qui augmentent le plus aux
etats unis trois marques de sondes
heures juste avant et c'est pas de
l'anti américanisme primaire mais je
crois que 30 peut aussi compter sur par
rapport à la question kurde sur la
culture invraisemblable de l'opinion
américaine j invraisemblable c'est comme
la plus grande puissance du monde
dia ternésiens quel est l'âge est
partout etc mais c'est des gens qui
prennent le quai ont très peu de
passeport par exemple ils voyagent très
bon c'est un grand pays très diversifiée
mais ils voyagent très peu à l'étranger
et les j'avais fait des études
comparatives c'était stupéfiant de voir
effectivement le degré d'ignorance des
américains ce qui fait que souvent les
étudiants américains avaient un niveau
moindre que l'opinion générale des
français moyens français données
internes de plus ont effectivement pour
nos internautes la mort d'al baghdadi
devra profiter à la réaction de donald
trump pour leur a posé la question et
vous et oui à répondre
vous êtes 52% plutôt un répondent oui et
non à 48%
matile broc et vous seriez américaine du
coup mon voteriez non j'aurais tendance
à rejoindre globalement le ring aidé
c'est que alors déjà l'élection n'est
pas dans six semaines deux mois va être
quand même se passer pas mal de choses
faut se rappeler aussi du contexte dans
lequel ils évoluent en ce moment il est
quand même en procédure d'une petite
meute qui est en train d'avancer il ya
diverses auditions qui sont faites ah
oui mais mine de rien ça c'est sur du
long terme
et ça on va en ré entendre parler au fur
et à mesure dans la presse alors que la
moi j'aurais plus tendance à voir le
très bonne chose que monsieur el
baghdadi était que ce soit fini on va
dire mais je suis pas sûr que ce soit ça
qui puisse favoriser la réélection de
trump sur ces annonces voilà ça peut
être un ensemble
effectivement c'est plutôt l'économie
qui pourrait faire ça mais je doute que
ce soit que ce soit ce coup d'éclat on
le voyait je parle sous votre contrôle
mais c'est vrai que au moment des
attentats en france
la cote de popularité de françois
hollande avait grimpé en flèche puis ça
avait duré deux mois même pas un mois et
est retombé en janvier pour janvier 2015
et après le même façon 18 parler de ces
choses là comme ça mais les attentats
suis comme il plusieurs vagues
les 28 ventes n'y avait plus il y avait
les mots simples opinions mais c'est ça
donc c'est vraiment très très peu très
peu durable